il y en a assez de se la jouer chacun
pour soi chacun de son côté
la mutuelle des ménages prévoyante ce
sont des êtres humains et vous avant
tout en cas d'urgence vous pouvez
contacter notre assistance 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
parce que votre santé n'attend pas une
mutuelle qui répond toujours présent
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
cliquez et vérifier le dès maintenant
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
check up votre émission santé et
bien-être
au programme dans ce numéro vous
découvrirez le projet jirau lift un
fauteuil roulant révolutionnaire qui a
remporté le concours docteur
d'entrepreneurs des rencontres
universités entreprises 2016 nous
parlerons ensuite des enfants
intellectuellement précoces
comment les détecter et mieux les suivre
en milieu scolaire nous reviendrons
également sur les rencontres de
l'innovation autour du handicap
organisée à vélizy et pour terminer
focus sur anaïs une petit plaisir oise
de cinq ans atteinte de tetra paresi une
forme d'infirmité moteur cérébral mais
pour commencer il est le fruit de la
rencontre entre l'association handi pod
et le laboratoire des systèmes
d'ingénierie de versailles
le projet jirau lift porté par le
docteur lambert traîneau race a remporté
le 25 mars dernier le concours docteur
entrepreneurs des rencontres universités
entreprises 2016 un fauteuil roulant
électrique qui permet de se redresser
ouvrant ainsi de nouvelles perspectives
sociales professionnelles et quotidienne
reportage
ouais on par exemple dans un milieu
professionnel et on a accès à des objets
qui sont à hauteur donc comme ça la
personne elle est indépendante
c'est un dispositif de locomotion
novateur d'un côté un fauteuil roulant
verticalisateur de l'autre un gyropode
du type ségou et l'assemblage de ces
deux technologies donnent giraud lift un
dispositif d'embarquement réduit qui
permet de se déplacer de se verticaliser
en même temps on peut se déplacer aussi
bien à pied que de bol ça c'est la
fonction principale c'était l'objectif
principal mais on bénéficie aussi des
avantages du gyropode segway en
contrôler de manière intuitif on se
penche en avant pour avancer on se
penche en arrière pour reculer entrer
dans un ascenseur ou passer par des
portes classiques grâce à sa taille
réduite ce fauteuil offre des capacités
de déplacement et de franchissement
extrêmement large avoir accès à des
objets en hauteur pouvoir être la même
hauteur d'une personne quand on lui
parle
après il ya tous les avantages d'être
debout c'est tous les avantages
physiologique donc circulation du sang
réduction des escarres consolidation des
eaux
le déplacement du fauteuil se fait grâce
à une petite télécommande ou bien via
son smartphone grâce à une application
dédiée plus d'une année de travail a été
nécessaire pour la réalisation de ce
premier prototype
un travail récompensé puisque giraud
livre a reçu les prix du jury et du
public lors du concours docteur
entrepreneurs des rencontres universités
entreprises 2016 on a d'un point de vue
entreprenariale le juré qui valorise le
business plan et le projet en tant qu en
entrepreneuriat et le public pour le
projet là c'est vraiment plus j'irai
physique plus charnelle de dire vrai
c'est quelque chose qui est important
pour ces personnes-là ou pour des
usagers et donc ça vraiment ça permet de
mettre en avant le projet et
entrepreneurs prochain objectif pour le
docteur traîneau race la
commercialisation de son produit vers la
fin de l'année 2017 pour un prix
d'environ 9000 euros
l'enfant intellectuellement précoces
fait dans le champ intellectuel ces
acquisitions différemment et plus
rapidement que les autres enfants
nombre de ces enfants poursuit une
scolarité sans aucune difficulté en
revanche d'autres ont besoin de
bénéficier d'adaptation scolaire
apporter ses réponses aux personnels de
l'éducation nationale c'était l'objet de
la conférence de la psychologue jeanne
siaud facchin le 30 mars dernier à
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
empathique ou égoïste sur adapté ou
inadaptés bien que paradoxaux ces
exemples sont des caractéristiques
représentatif du fonctionnement de
l'élève intellectuellement précoces une
attitude souvent déconcertante pour les
professeurs confronté à ses enfants le
30 mars dernier la spécialiste jeanne
siaud facchin donnait une conférence à
destination des personnels de
l'éducation des yvelines certains
enfants qui vont être catalogué
d'enfants turbulents
ou d'enfants avec un trouble de
l'attention alors qu'en fait ces enfants
ils ont besoin qu'on les regarde avec
une autre grille de lecture en fête au
moins ma mission que j'ai accepté c'est
de proposer une grille de lecture pour
que enfin les enseignants puissent
ressentir presque plus dans leur coeur
qui sont ces enfants plutôt que de les
penser avec des idées préconçues
comme ils peuvent la voir dans la tête
favoriser sa prise de position si
l'élève est trop effacé ou lui proposer
un contrat s'il est insolent dès que les
détails et pour agir avec chaque élève
sont donnés par l'association nationale
pour les enfants intellectuellement
précoces répondre à leurs besoins mais
aussi savoir les détecter en créant des
cellules dédiées au sein de certains
établissements
nous nous avons des psychologues
scolaires également qu'ils sont à même
de faire des observations dans les
classes de recueillir des informations
de leurs collègues et de faire en sorte
que le repérage soit fait nous essayons
au niveau départemental à partir d'un
groupe de travail départemental de faire
en sorte que l'ensemble du territoire
yvelinois soit mallet et qu'on ait des
correspondants sur tout le territoire
qui sont à même d'une part d'accompagner
les enseignants mais aussi d'apporter
aux parents une première réponse
une cellule fonctionne déjà à
rambouillet alors qu'une seconde est en
train de se mettre en place à saint
quentin en yvelines pour une couverture
totale de tout le bassin d'éducation
yvelinois d'ici la fin de l'année
vendredi 7 avril l'iut de vélizy a
accueilli la deuxième édition du
colloque en diversité organisé par
l'université de paris saclay l'événement
rassemblé une vingtaine d'ingénieurs
venus présenter leurs projets
d'innovation autour du handicap un
secteur économique trop peu représenté
selon ces entrepreneurs
un reportage de camille lambert depuis
trois ans marie claire un handicap mais
il ne se voit pas à la suite d'un
traumatisme crânien la dû réapprendre
les gestes du quotidien
aujourd'hui à l'afl déplacement au
colloque en diversité à l'iut de vélizy
pour tester bcap un logiciel permettant
d'analyser sa conduite automobile s'est
arrêtée sur des machines et à charge des
évaluations
embellir et m
et salaires
c'est très bien comme à n'importe qui
même en étant est permise et c'est
réconfortant
selon l'insee sur les 12 millions de
français handicapés 80% à handicap
invisible comme marie claire organisée
par l'université paris saclay cet
événement avait pour but de montrer le
handicap comme vecteur d'innovation
technologique prendre en compte le
handicap en amont permet de faire des
produits beaucoup plus innovant est bien
plus intéressante pour tous on a tous un
jour ou l'autre besoin d'une assistance
donc autant il pensait en amont alors
essentiellement s'adresse aux chercheurs
aux entrepreneurs à tous ceux qui ont
envie de développer des projets qui
permettent d'avoir une société ouverte à
tous
c'est s'ouvrir à un marché extrêmement
grand dans lequel tout le monde peut se
retrouver et où donc a effectivement des
potentiels à créer applications pour
personnes malvoyantes ou simulateur de
fauteuils roulants
une vingtaine d'ingénieurs ont présenté
leur projet avec démonstrations ce
logiciel on peut l'utiliser dans
plusieurs optiques d'abord dans une
petite de sensibilisation en fait dans
une optique d'apprentissage pour les
personnes qui ont récemment handicapés
qui tout simplement pour
les architectes pour pouvoir vérifier
l'accessibilité de certains lieux
publics en fauteuil roulant la majorité
des projets présentés sont encore en
phase de test avant leur entrée sur le
marché en 2015 l'insee estimait que 50 %
des français sont ou seront confrontés
au handicap pour eux mêmes ou pour un de
leurs proches
anaïs une petit plaisir oise de cinq ans
est atteinte de tetra parisy une forme
d'infirmité moteur cérébral qui l'avait
handicapé des quatre membres
un handicap qui a bouleversé sa famille
qui tente de donner à leurs enfants un
maximum de chances d'accéder à son
autonomie en plus d'être suivis à
l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches
la petite fille pratique plusieurs
méthodes de rééducation dites
alternatives un engagement coûteux qui a
poussé ses parents a créé l'association
anaïs du rêve à l'espoir pour aider au
financement de tous ses soins
tout le monde était là à l'aise à la
barre alexandre il est pas marqué avec
centre à cinq ans à sa naissance un
manque d'oxygène à créer des lésions
cérébrales conduisant à une tetra parisy
une forme d'infirmité moteur cérébral la
petite fille est suivi par plusieurs
praticiens à l'hôpital raymond-poincaré
de garches
aujourd'hui après l'école elle a rendez
vous avec laeticia sont l'ergothérapeute
qui la suit depuis trois ans c'est une
petite fille qui présente de grosses
difficultés motrices de grosses
difficultés de coordination motrice sur
l'ensemble du corps y compris sur la
sphère du coc faciale pas là une des
priorités aussi chez cette petite ça
c'est de pouvoir pouvoir s'exprimer elle
pouvoir communiquer avec son entourage
l'objectif de ces séances d'ergothérapie
rendre autonomes et indépendantes la
petite fille dans les activités de la
vie quotidienne jeudi
7 mars à bry jeudi 7 avril
jeudi 7 avril pour ces séances
anaïs utilise une synthèse vocale une
tablette qui permet à l'enfant de
communiquer et d'avoir de vraies
conversations en fait celle des
combinaisons de pictogrammes qui vont
nous permettre d'aller dans différents
différents registres
on va pouvoir conjuguer tous les verbes
à cet endroit là toute la ligne du haut
ça va être des catégories les habits les
animaux la nourriture voilà on va voir
tous les petits mots de liaison qui vont
être en verre etc le fait d'apprendre
toutes les combinaisons des pictogrammes
qui
qui va pouvoir permettre une
conversation après fonctionnel avec des
mots de liaison avec on peut enregistrer
des phrases on peut faire plein plein de
choses et on peut tout dire surtout un
appareil qui coûte plus de 8000 euros
mais indispensable à la petite fille
pour lui permettre de mieux communiquer
en marche de l'école anaïs suit des
séances d'orthophonie kinésithérapie
ergothérapie ainsi que divers soins à
l'hôpital des semaines très lourde pour
une petite fille pleine de vie
après avoir passé sa journée entre
l'école et l'hôpital
anaïs rentrer chez elle mais sa journée
n'est pas terminée soucieux du
développement de leur fille les parents
sont allés chercher plus loin que ce que
pouvait proposer la médecine française
des méthodes dites alternatives souvent
non reconnu par la france
c'est beaucoup d'investissement parce
que du coup il faut rééduquer donc tout
aussi bien la marche mais la parole que
les bras et du coup au quotidien il faut
la stimuler la solliciter même si elle
est très très volontaire et qu'elle a
très envie de progresser
ces thérapies c'est à l'étranger que les
parents sont allés les chercher
méthode et santis biofeedback ou encore
la méthode medek à laquelle anaïs
s'exerce tous les soirs quand redescend
doucement aux pieds les jambes puis les
jambes mais les mains devant je te tiens
les lendemains des exercices qui expose
l'enfant à la gravité dans l'objectif
d'obtenir une réponse active elle fait
des exercices en fait par exemple on
monte mon temps sur sur des boîtes en
bois où on la met en situation de
déséquilibre pour qu'elles puissent
appréhender et retrouver son équilibre
et ça lui permet comme ça de garder une
posture bien plus droite une méthode
très physique mais chronophage pour les
parents anaïs réalise tous les soirs des
séances d'une demi-heure environ mais
qui selon eux portent leurs fruits
on a vu qu'elle a enquête faisait
énormément de progrès notamment sur la
marche parce que là au mois de décembre
elle a pu faire ses premiers pas tout
seul
et on essaie de la stimuler au quotidien
pour pour qu'elle puisse continuer à
avancer
une partie de ces thérapies se fait à
l'étranger notamment en espagne des
déplacements très coûteux qui ont
nécessité la création d'une association
pour aider au financement de ses soins
mais aussi pour le matériel trop peu
remboursés par les assurances sociales
anaïs une petite fille extrêmement
soutenue par ses parents qui mettent
toutes les chances de son côté pour
améliorer son état physique avec
l'espoir de la voir peut-être un jour
marcher et parler comme tout le monde
si vous souhaitez et des analystes
rendez vous sur le site internet de
l'association anaïs du rêve à l'espoir
qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
quant à moi je vous dis au revoir
c'était le dernier numéro du magazine
chèque de la saison je tiens à remercier
patrick jacques de dixmude qui a opéré
sur tous les plateaux de l'émission
durant toute l'année mais sur toi grand
merci à vous téléspectateurs de nous
avoir suivis